allison's arc in season two
might be my absolute favorite of season
two
and really just the growth from season
one through the second season is
something else so
when did you first learn what was gonna
happen with the character in season two
did you
already know by the time that they
pitched the the role of you originally
yeah so i think i think when we ended
you know i think our netflix producers
were so we're just like so
hype on the first season that i think
you know they were already having
conversations about
a second season and kind of you know
beginning those talks of like okay if we
did the second season like what would it
be about and where do we go from here
we've like
this season is so good like how are we
gonna top that and so i think we all
kind of
left the first season with like
knowing not that we were getting a
second season but knowing that like if
we did
steve our showrunner was really
interested in following the
the graphic novels in the sense of like
having dallas be a part of it and
the jfk assassination and so for me i
just was like great
that's dope however you have now cast a
black woman as alison which is
amazing but then you
it it it is impossible for us not to
address the fact that
if they go back to the 60s you will be
throwing allison into the segregated
south as a black woman
and and what that that will shape
if not be her entire storyline for the
season of like what that is and and that
is something that
she will not have in common with the
rest of her siblings and that is
something that she will be in
she will be alone in that um and and so
you know i think i i definitely knew and
then when the second season
you know got announced and and they
started the writer's room and they
started writing you know it
i think the conversation was like how
far are we gonna go into this
and how is alison going to be involved
and how much is she going to be involved
and
and what does that mean and also like
you know is she going to have her powers
back and if she does is she going to use
them
um and so i it was a huge it was a huge
conversation i know for
for the writer's room and and steve of
how how deep allison was gonna be in the
movement
um and i think you know the couple
conversations that him and i had about
it in the beginning i just was like i
think we're doing a huge disservice
if we do not take that as an opportunity
to like really just have her
you know ingratiate herself in this
movement
and and and become a part of a part of
it and take that as an opportunity um
for our show and for this platform that
we have um
and so yeah i think i was i was nervous
as hell
to you know tackle something like the
civil rights movement such a like a
monumental
period of time for the african-american
experience and america in general
um but and i also think you know but i
was also honored
to have that opportunity and to in it
and you know when i auditioned for the
show never in a million years if i think
allison would be like taking on the
civil rights movement you know what i
mean in any season of the show it just
was not
remotely on my mind of like tackling
social injustice and and
systemic racism and that being a part of
this show and also
you know this you know ellen ellen
through vania's character
is is is coming head-to-head with you
know the lgbtq
um you know experience in of that time
which was still considered illegal and a
mental illness and you know we're taking
on some really
bold and we've always kind of been
tackling klaus and his mental health and
and and and you know his drug addiction
and and that kind of thing so i think
you know it's just there's some heavy
hitting topics this season and i think
you know we were all really excited but
all
very very very you know
um opinionated on wanting to get it
right and and
and deal with all of these things and
depict them only with respect
yeah you you guys definitely kind of run
away
with doing that i mean allison in
particular is just so inspiring
how she gets involved in the movement
even though she is well aware that you
know by 2019 nothing's been solved and
the fact that she's
right a choice to commit and see it
through is just
i don't know my heart was going to
explode
i'm going to put the the spoiler warning
up for season two right now because i
wanted to stick with this topic a little
more and let you discuss it yeah
but i don't know what you know about
season three
yet but with everything she does with
the civil rights movement in
season two how are you hoping that they
kind of
hold on to that and let her bring that
to a new timeline
yeah you know i think i think the
lessons that allison is taking away
um from this second season are immense i
think she is
we're seeing a really new allison we're
seeing we're seeing an allison that is
kind of
has like stripped of all of her crutches
and her vices
and and and you know she's she's kind of
coming from a place of
of of abusing her power and and using
them for selfish reasons and and
is at a a real low and is riddled with
like regret
and guilt and kind of looking at a life
that outside of her daughter
feels meaningless and and and
superficial
and and so i think the allison that we
meet in the second season is
is you know she's had to scale it all
the way back she's had to
she's had to you know she doesn't have
her power she doesn't have her family
she doesn't have
you know the notoriety and the fame and
the career and she doesn't know where
claire is
um and so i think you know she because
she doesn't have her power she's had to
she'd have to be observant and she's had
to listen and she's had to slow things
down and she's had to
approach the world in a new way on top
of
being in the middle of the segregated
south in the middle of this movement
and and i think she's we're finding her
she's she's finding this new self-worth
that i think is
is really beautiful to kind of watch and
i think for the first time in her life
she's like
looking in the mirror and actually like
liking that reflection because i think
she knows that everything she has now
she's worked for and she has a community
that supports her and has a community
that that loves her
and has found a man that loves her
without all the things that made her
lovable
um and so i think you know i think those
are huge lessons and i think the biggest
one also is that like she doesn't need
her power
to be powerful and i think that is
i think that is how she has approached
everything in her life up until this
point that she's like i'm powerful
because i have powers
but i think this season she's learning
the power that is in her actual voice
and the message that she wants to
to carry and and pass on and and the
fight that she the fights that she wants
to fight and and
and the you know whatever it is that she
wants to take on i think she's starting
to learn that
you know she doesn't need her powers to
do that and so i think
going into a third season i mean if we
did it would be amazing to kind of
see how that manifests when they're you
know seemingly back
in their normal timeline if they are and
i think um
it would be such a disservice to not
kind of take the lessons that she's been
learning
this season and translate that to
another season and also
um you know and also i think it would be
really interesting to watch her
and educational and and and informative
for her to
deal with the traumas of this past
season because it's not really
you know we don't really see we you know
we in her landing scene we see her get
chased by the men
and and run into the beauty salon and
then like kind of start her journey
there
but at the end of the day if you like
you know i think she is she for three
years she is in like survival mode
you know what i mean i think for three
years she is she is
having to normalize the violence that
she's seeing in the street and normalize
the whites only signs and normalize
these
things that you know she's coming from a
place where those didn't exist i'm not
saying she didn't know about them
and i'm not saying she didn't face
prejudice and racism and
microaggressions obviously
there's no doubt that she did but like
the level of which they are at in the
time that they are in
has got to affect her and it is trauma
and there's tr there's going to be
trauma there and so i would love to
actually like explore
her mental health having essentially
lived through
these these three years of of you know
obviously there were beautiful moments
and and relationships that she's walking
away from with love and
and she's kind of this new person but i
also think like
she's had to be strong for so long
you